[Music]
deep beneath the geysers and hot springs
of Yellowstone Caldera lies a magma
chamber produced by a hot spot in the
Earth's mantle as the magma moves
towards the Earth's surface it
crystallizes to form young hot igneous
rocks the heat from these rocks drives
groundwater towards the surface as the
water cools ions precipitate out as
mineral crystals including quartz
crystals from silicon and oxygen
feldspar from potassium aluminium
silicon and oxygen Galena
from lead and sulfur many of these
crystals have signature shapes take this
cascade of pointed quartz or this pile
of Galena cubes but what causes them to
grow into these shapes again and again
part of the answer lies in their atoms
every crystals atoms are arranged in a
highly organized repeating pattern this
pattern is the defining feature of a
crystal and isn't restricted to minerals
sand ice sugar chocolate ceramics metals
DNA and even some liquids have
crystalline structures each crystalline
materials atomic arrangement falls into
one of six different families cubic
tetragonal orthorhombic monoclinic
triclinic and hexagonal given the
appropriate conditions crystals will
grow into geometric shapes that reflect
the arrangement of their atoms take
Galena which has a cubic structure
composed of lead and sulfur atoms the
relatively large lead atoms are arranged
in a three-dimensional grid ninety
degrees from one another while the
relatively small sulfur atoms fit neatly
between them as the crystal grows
locations like these attract sulfur
atoms while lead will tend to bond to
these places eventually they will
complete the grid of bonded atoms
this means the ninety degree grid
pattern of Gallinas crystalline
structure is reflected in the visible
shape of the crystal
quartz meanwhile has a hexagonal
crystalline structure this means that on
one plane its atoms are arranged in
hexagons in three dimensions these
hexagons are composed of many
interlocking pyramids made up of one
silicon atom and four oxygen atoms so
the signature shape of a quartz crystal
is a six-sided column with pointed tips
depending on environmental conditions
most crystals have the potential to form
multiple geometric shapes for example
diamonds which form deep in the Earth's
mantle have a cubic crystalline
structure and can grow into either cubes
or octahedrons
which shape a particular diamond grows
into depends on the conditions where it
grows including pressure temperature and
chemical environment while we can't
directly observe growth conditions in
the mantle laboratory experiments have
shown some evidence that diamonds tend
to grow into cubes at lower temperatures
and octahedrons at higher temperatures
trace amounts of water silicon germanium
or magnesium might also influence a
diamond shape and diamonds never
naturally grow into the shapes found in
jewelry those diamonds have been cut to
showcase sparkle and clarity
environmental conditions can also
influence weather crystals form a tall
glass is made of melted quartz sand but
it isn't crystalline that's because
glass cools relatively quickly and the
atoms do not have time to arrange
themselves into the ordered structure of
a quartz crystal instead the random
arrangement of the atoms in the melted
glass is locked in upon cooling many
crystals don't form geometric shapes
because they grow in extremely close
quarters with other crystals rocks like
granite are full of crystals but none
have recognizable shapes as magma cools
and solidifies many minerals within it
crystallize at the same time and quickly
run out of space and certain crystals
like turquoise don't grow into any
discernible geometric shape in
environmental conditions even given
adequate space every crystals atomic
structure has unique properties and
while these properties may not have any
bearing on human emotional needs they do
have powerful applications in materials
science and medicine have you ever
wondered why you can see through glass
or what fire is made of did you know
Gold doesn't originally come from our
planet find out more about the
fascinating makeup of our environment
with this playlist
[Music]